this is a starboy zeal king in the sting
zeal what's good podcast just got done
doing some dirt i mean work at that
big double d dirty double d right there
y'all king of the state blaze them up
bro white people with dreads
you feel me yes sir oh
not buskieski dang i like this guy
very unique man zeal is his name zeal
i like culture appropriation shout out
to dunkin donuts dude over there dude
and let's play one of my favorite videos
of all time if you'll go to the dunkin
don
it's burns down a dunkin donuts burned
down
oh this is the best video that's ever
happened dude julie a lot of people
in shimokin are upset that dunkin donuts
is closed because they didn't have
anywhere else to go for coffee and
donuts
today we also learned new information
about the teenage girl police
charged with setting the place on fire
yellow tape surrounds the dunkin donuts
on west sunbury street in shimoku dead
seriously popular
shout out it's closed until further
notice there's a lot of people that's
definitely going to miss it no doubt
about it
a teenager is charged with starting a
fire inside the restaurant on saturday
night a restaurant
the case has extensive damage police
officer ray psycho says no one
place has extensive damage psycho says
the fire fireworks
that's going on the toilet paper
dispenser was lit on fire and within
about a minute the entire place was
filled up with smoke
the mother did explain that she's
recently been put on new medication
his name's officer race who admitted to
setting the fire is currently at a
juvenile detention center
now i have to rely on myself to go to
maybe a turkey hill or something where i
don't like their donuts i rather the
donuts at dunkin donuts
and i'm kind of dealing with it but i
really miss dunkin donuts
okay i get some coffee powerade if i'm
dehydrated
i sit there all the time if i have any
like legal work that i need to do i go
there i meet with my attorneys there
i'm gonna miss that place when it don't
open up
damn it yeah a lot of my friends go in
there
get the cold coffee with iced coffee i
guess it's called
people miss their vocals what planet is
that
for old coffee what's it called frozen
water coffee
it's a location where you can meet up
with your friends it's the only thing
this town has
gang [ __ ] bro [ __ ] was hilarious shout
out shamokin bro
shout out people sweat and shout out to
everybody that survives out there in
dunkin donuts when they trying to burn
them down there
[ __ ] dude shout out to this dude rocking
the dreads kind of similar with that 16
year old with braces
really takes some courage to do that and
my only problem with them they smell
like
[ __ ] bro not if you smell like hummus
not if you
thread a little bit of potpourri up in
there or something or put a cinnamon
stick in each one especially with the
holidays lumen do you could throw a
pumpkin spice backsplash on those
[ __ ]
ropes bruh you know what i'm saying make
your whole [ __ ] world smell like a
damn starbucks dog
you'll be [ __ ] in an instant
hell yeah i'm i'm gonna probably sting
the white dreads i just
sting them if you want dude yeah i
believe anybody
could do the dreads if they really want
to do them it takes a brave person to do
them i take some time
too yeah put wax in it and [ __ ] and we
don't see a lot of asian dreads why is
that
cat hmm good point you know i've never
noticed that until this point
there aren't a lot of dreads has ever
been an asian with dreads huh
maybe jackie chan in that one movie like
a forbidden kingdom or something yeah
dreads in that it's probably a way you
get a wig yeah
i don't think asian people can get a wig
make dreads
maybe that's why it just doesn't vibe
does it oh there's a couple
of dresses linsanity dude
dude and he was a national champion with
the toronto raptors people forget i mean
he played as many minutes as you and i
but yeah i hear you
but he played him dude at least some
[ __ ]
janitor didn't score 40 on him and his
[ __ ] chubby buddy
i think they did oh yeah i'm pretty sure
they did that's a good point
playing over in china now for orange
chicken so i think we're all right
huh that looks like chin a little bit if
chin was more gangster oh
that's a little racist derrick but
whatever
chin definitely starts to resemble a lot
of other asian men i've met
i will admit that part but i think he
does it by choice he tries not to stand
out
i wish chin would grow dreads but he
can't
he could if he wants to no he's
struggling with the shaved head
he could if he wants to now the lord's
getting us here again oh
it could be man maybe the lord doesn't
want it bro the lord don't put a crop on
everybody man
sometimes for some people lord's your
barber yeah that's
no choice to go to that barber shop
seventh heavens barbershop is open
all the time for some people 24 7.
uh good luck out there man at the dunkin
donuts i see the fall leaves in the
background man it's that seasonal time
it's a beautiful time of year guys yeah
good for you man with the dirt the king
in this game